nadia mourad Olivia RG bechard are the  two winners of this year's sakharov  prize they survived Islamic state to  brutality in Iraq and denounced the  genocide of Yazidis that's the amount of  budget cuts proposed by e-government us  Parliament says no because the money is  needed to boost youth employment and to  tackle the migration crisis that's the  percentage of deaths in Europe due to  cardiovascular disease transformed oils  like trans fats are a major cause the  parliament called from mandatory limit  the number of refugee minors registered  in the EU in 2015 is impressive EU  lawmakers think appropriate reception  centers and access to education are key  for the children comprehensive  cooperative critical and constructive  any pedes want to reset the relations  with Iran by expanding trade but they  remain critical of the use of a death  penalty in Iran